why did you feel it was important to
cast Michael Madsen oh my Cole was I
think the way in structure is a road
film very ancient structure if you look
at you know Homer's Iliad it's really a
road movie on Santa moving but it's a
you know it's a road trip and what the
road trip does allow is those episodic
appearances of characters you know that
people bump along the way and that on a
production allows you all right you
might be able to use a guy for a day or
two shooting and if that's the case you
might be able to even contemplate
knocking of somebody's you know a door
who is a big star and is known globally
and you know that that Superboy made
sense it wasn't like you know we have
him for a week or ten days Michaels
there for one day and it was you know
kind of like all right let's cram him in
one day let's try to make the most of it
and we did you know is he's such AI mean
he went to Serbia with us to promote the
film he came to Europe you know he's
going to heave showed up at the premiere
he received Best Actor I have a
Supporting Actor Award which is
surprising because such a small part but
not too small it's definitely there you
know uh and I know it was one of those
things like okay we do need a legitimacy
from people who won't get it is all
right you have all these people in the
great dancer audiences but nobody know
they are in Hollywood like we put
Michael matza huh you know him right
well he's in the movie too and it's
surprisingly how a lot of people do
refer to this woman's on Michael Madsen
phone
you